monsieur peabody est diplômé de harvard
et médor de sa promotion il ouvrit la
voie à la recherche sur les énergies
alternatives et la césure perdu il
inventa le tchèque
le planking le back side et la zumba
mais la chose la plus difficile à
laquelle va être confronté le chien le
plus extraordinaire du monde quelles que
soient les défis à relever
quelle que soit la distance qui semble
nous séparer je suis avec toi être un
père normal à les dix mois qui on attend
la famille peterson et note-t-elle j'y
peux rien arranger les choses mais ne
lui parle pas des chronos battre l'appli
le chronomat c'est une machine à
remonter le temps moi
sherman pas ni pourquoi vous êtes
habillé comme dans la grèce en turquie
s'est perdu en egypte en ciel je me suis
fiancé à toutankhamon
là on est tombé en panne tu as pris le
chronomat oui elle insiste yves bonté
divine
tu vas pas le programmer le voyage dans
le temps nous devons réécrire l'histoire
si nous voulons sauver l'univers
l'egypte ancienne sais-tu cela monsieur
peabody a tout eu mon petit copain quoi
tout ça rime avec foot et rose de la
crête quelqu'un les et ça pour nous un
cadeau yes il ressemble à notre cheval à
nous l'abordons l'intérieur se serait
pas poli peabody pour vous savez je
n'avais pas vu venir celle là le 12
février qu'elle maîtrise est patent le
chien le plus cool de l'histoire à
trottoir va nous projeter
german c'est un travers le temps une
brèche s'est ouverte dans le continuum
espace temps on dirait que le passé
vient vers nous
ni ma fiancée à quoi monsieur peabody et
sherman les voyages dans le temps
éloignez vous de ce globe du futur
sachez que je ne reçois d'ordre de
personne ne tasse pas mon pote le 12
février au cinéma en 3d